hello there this week I have the
pleasure of hosting Quinn henyk Quinn is
a doctor of physical therapy he's the
head of sports rehabilitation for
juggernaut training systems and the man
behind clinical athlete comm he is about
as no-bullshit as you can get and I've
wanted to have him on the podcast for so
long as far as I can see
mobility is this like Charlotte and rich
awash world where no one really knows
what's going on and there's so much
disinformation that it feels like the
Trump presidential campaign all over
again which isn't good right people need
mobility they want to be mobile within
particular ranges of motion they want to
be able to do an overhead squat and a
normal squat and complete a variety of
tasks that require their bodies to be
mobile but there doesn't appear to be
any consensus or appropriate information
Quinn does a series on YouTube called
mobility myths and as soon as I saw that
I knew that hard to have a conversation
with him I think we went better than I
could have hoped of just about much to
pick my jaw up off the floor after
finishing with him and we go through
what the science says about typical
approaches to achieving mobility we look
at the word mobility flexibility
stability what do all of these words
mean in a performance context what are
the typical approaches and their
efficacy their usefulness within
training from static stretching to
dynamic stretching to soft tissue work
what do they actually do if anything and
I think this summer there's some very
surprising takeaways even if you're not
a highly functioning or even moderately
functioning athlete even if you're a
couch potato this information is so
important to understand
how our bodies work in relation to
moving
I couldn't believe some of the some of
the summaries that he gave me and some
of the conclusions that he's drawn
hopefully we're going to save people an
awful lot of time in the gym and we're
going to improve their ability to
understand their body and to adapt their
training to the needs that they've got
so I'm gonna stop bloviating here
because this podcast just it speaks for
itself
hope you enjoy it here is Quinn hanok
[Music]
so Quinn henyk doctor of physical
therapy head of sports rehabilitation
for juggernaut training systems and the
man behind clinical athlete comm how are
you today Chris I'm doing well man
thanks for having me on thank you for
coming on man I really appreciate it so
I want to cut sort of straight to the
chase here researching mobility online
for me can feel a little bit like a
minefield of disinformation for every
article that says yes one approach that
does seem to be 20 arguing against it do
you think there's a lack of clarity with
what's published online
Oh 100% it's it as confusing it is for
you it's as equally confusing to me the
the word mobility is not well-defined
it's not really defined at all you know
in physical therapy school when we used
the word mobility it was regarding like
patient in patients in hospitals whether
they can walk you know whether they can
roll over in bed bed mobility it was
like functional things functional tasks
like that and so I think in the last you
know five to eight years or whatever the
word mobility this nebulous term has
probably the biggest buzzword you know
has been in that time frame and I don't
think we have a good grasp on it you
know you'll get is it synonymous with
range of motion is it there's an equal
the control of movement you'll you know
see some people describe it that way
coma zone of his old range of sins right
yeah exactly so when you say I gotta
work on my mobility we don't nobody
knows what the hell that means so I try
not to use the word but I have kind of
gauged my interpretation of it because
it is so popular I tend to put the word
as synonymous with range of motion well
so hey what what does mobility mean to
you it for me it means the potential for
a movement meaning do you have the
hardware to perform the task meaning
again do your joints get into the
positions that we plan to Train
so if if we're talking about the hip and
our positions that we want to train is
the deep squat and we want to squat
below parallel or hips below 90 degrees
if you lay on the table can I move your
hip joint past or through that range of
motion without apprehension or issue or
a hard some type of hard blocks and type
of structural block and in many cases
the reason I define it like that is
because it's a way for me to create the
the buy-in that most people do not have
the limitations that they perceive to
have in regards to their structure ok I
think I think a lot of people well they
they blame their structure for not being
able to hit certain positions in
training when the Audi is those
positions and the or and/or those
training modalities are simply too
intense and too complex for their
particular athletic prowess at the time
and so if we simplify the word mobility
because simply can your joints get into
the positions let's establish that first
ok and if the answer is yes but [ __ ]
goes well can I cuss on this show fire
away my ok and with some type of
increase in intensity be that actual
weight on the bar under load exactly
velocity fatigue all these markers that
can make something more complex or motor
control is more needed and then you're
unable to hit the positions well that
has nothing to do with your structure
that has to do with your motor control
and your strength or pick you know
whatever athletic attribute that's
required for that task yeah go ahead
I was gonna say so does other other
terms that we need that are pertinent to
this discussion stability flexibility
mobility I hear all of these terms
thrown around is there a way that you
can create a paradigm of how these all
fit together in your context of
conceptually you can try you know the
reality is the more terms that we use
the more convoluted things get however I
try to anytime that we hear a new term
or start to use a term in this
context I try to see if it's actually
been defined in the scientific
literature mobility has not stability
has been it's a little bit more
consistent in its in its definition
still kind of some some you know
variability there but it's actually in
the scientific literature so stability
is typically defined as the ability of a
system to stay and or return to a
homeostasis after some type of
perturbation or stressor okay so in
regards to movement it's the whether or
not it's static or dynamic stability if
it's static I'm trying to hold a
position a desired position and resist
outside forces that could be the barbell
that could be gravity there could be an
opponent yeah so that's static stability
dynamic stability would be I'm
attempting to move through a desired
path again while trying to resist
external forces in the literature they
use the word perturbation tongue-tied if
I say that too much like those input
intubation or debate yep and ma yes so
think about this something like the
overhead squat from the belly button up
you're looking for relative static
stability yeah you're trying you're
trying to lock that overhead position in
place but from the from the hip knee and
ankle perspective you're looking at a
dynamic stability situation where you're
trying to move through a desired path
while offsetting other forces that are
attempting to take you out of said path
okay yeah globally how do you put that
together when you've got both static and
move and dynamic stability that to me
then the overarching theme is is motor
skill acquisition motor control it's a
lot less sexy than mobility isn't it I
think it's octa because I think motor
Scott position is the sexiest of all
that's the heritage of a doctor showing
through right there I think
exactly so if we think motor control as
this overarching theme of taking it's
your so it's task plus individual plus
environment okay so if we don't and this
is what we're you know we there's about
25 different rabbit holes we could jump
into but you gotta kind of get when it
comes to human movement we've got to get
rid of the dichotomies and the
black-and-whites
because human movement is so variable
the task itself can be done a million
different ways and the human is so
variable in in so many different ways so
we're looking at like optimizing things
or general guidelines but if we think
about motor control as it's specific to
the task
so one position may be optimal for one
thing and suboptimal for another so I'll
think about think about your spinal
position with an overhead squat well if
mine is absolutely terrible it is the
biggest point of contention in my
training okay so I was gonna say that I
was gonna contrast that with like a
competitive rower or like a strongman
who has to pick up a stone who has like
a turtle back yeah that's the optimal
position for that task so maybe you
maybe you're using that position for you
know the other thing I don't know what
amazing but it's definitely not helping
my overhead school at the moment so the
task matters the environment matters you
know what type of equipment are you
using what's what surface are you
standing on what are the implements and
then the individual what's the build of
the individual what's the training
history and the response all these
factors play in so all those things lump
into motor control and then motor skill
acquisition is basically what we do
every single day in the gym we're trying
to acquire skills under that I think is
where are these mobility stability
factors like okay let's do the joints
get into the positions can you control
those positions and then if the answer
is yes and yes now we can layer on
practice and skill and then we can link
into load and all the rest of it exactly
so factors like strength and power are
developed when as we're loading
intensity
over time yeah you know those attributes
take a long time okay
I think certainly from my experience and
most laymen understanding of this
mobility would probably be confused with
range of motion do you think that's
probably fair to say yeah it's me if you
can if you if someone believes that
someone's really mobile because they're
able to do the splits right so then I
guess the now the turn was a flexp and
extensibility kind of come into play too
so host flexibility is usually defined
as the the ability of all tissues
involved to get into a position so they
take your example of the splits it's the
muscles involved it's the connective
tissues you know the ligaments and the
joint capsule and everything that's
involved to allow that position to
happen and then within that
extensibility is usually referred to for
specifically the muscles so muscle I
think it must tense ability is what
people call flexibility a lot yeah
hoping when people say flexibility they
you know it's assumed that only the
muscles are involved when you hit a
position but there's a whole lot of
other types of tissues that have to be
you know stressed in to that scenario so
I this is where it gets so confusing
because it's extensibility flexibility
mobility just you know range of motion
yeah I like range of motion to be honest
most because that that tells the story
excursion of range of can I can you put
your shoulder over your head the
position that I want your shoulder when
that barbell is over your head does it
go there and if I move the joint in that
position it's obviously assumed that all
the soft tissues are going with if
you've got that range of motion
passively on the table but yet you don't
you can't express that range of motion
in a training scenario then we have to
develop these other qualities that we
talked about yep motor position
stability strength these you know these
types of things okay I think that I
think that starts to zero in on how
these elements play together so when
we're talking about someone
capacity to get into a particular
position I think a lot of the people who
are listening will be potentially
CrossFitters power lifters weight
lifters or someone who's looking at
perhaps making the transition across
into this so when we're talking about
someone getting into these positions how
much of this is enabled by someone's
natural physiology definitely plays a
part I think that it plays a part in
their ability to catch on right away and
or take more time I mean there are
people who walk into my door where
they've never you know this is just like
you said they want to do they want to
snatch the clean-and-jerk or they want
to squat they've never done it before
but I just say okay well put your feet
you know shoulder-width apart and keep
your feet flat and just sit down as far
as you can you know I just want to sit
I'll give them I give them minimal cues
I just want to see what's what's good
you know to see what I'm working with
yeah and there are some people who just
naturally rock bottom beautiful squad
yeah Wow they're like you know they look
at you and they're like you mean like
this and it's a perfect squad like what
like watching Ray Williams in front of
you is something like that totally
exactly so then it's like okay that's
basically the screen because it passed
my my initial test of can the joints get
into the positions now this person is
gonna need very appropriate and you know
progressive appropriately progressed
intensity and training and overload and
these types of things but they passed
the initial test of the joints go into
the positions there's no need to stretch
or try to passively tug and gain more
range of motion yeah or I understand I
definitely feel that sometimes when
we're in the gym and they'll be
especially a lot of girls who come in
for the first time and they'll have a
will be doing a squat snatch workout
let's say in CrossFit and they'll come
in with a PVC bar and just drop
underneath it beautifully and there's me
there's me sweating and shaking in the
back of the class with my entire
posterior chain turned on so hard that I
could pick up 200 kilos but I've got a
PVC bar overhead and to get myself into
that I've already mobilized for like an
hour beforehand and I'm just about
overhead with this
Seba and then certain certain newcomers
can just walk in and they've got this
beautiful overhead position and you know
some factors the play is natural
structure bony bony structure so at the
hip there are a lot of factors that can
make a squat position just simply more
natural feeling and more comfortable
it's like this the more shallow a
person's hip socket the generally the
deeper they can squat without feelings
of restriction in the hip hip saw okay
so that are altered more in front of the
pelvis as opposed to laterally will
allow the person to operate narrow and
kind of sink straight down
did an angel of the femoral neck so
there's tons of the point is you got to
kind of play with position squat
position and overhead position or very
our variable based on structure and that
definitely play the role and this and
the technique needs to be taught
appropriately to the person's physiology
exactly there's no especially with the
squat there there can't be a
one-size-fits-all because human anatomy
is so different it's it just it's so
clear that it has to be tailored to the
individual yeah there are some yeah I
certainly I certainly noticed that
sometimes I've traveled around to a lot
of different gyms over the last couple
of years and there's certainly some
coaches at certain gyms that I've been
to who've got the cookie cutter set of
cue cards for cues for lifting needs
that needs narrowing of toes turned in
whatever it might be when are you doing
for instance something like a wall ball
which for me is that a lot of people
seem to be able to find their own
natural way to drop into a wall ball and
and for me that involves driving my
knees out quite wide and that feels
lovely and I know that I'm efficient and
I know that it's safe and I know that I
don't get injured doing it that way and
then as you say sometimes you may go see
a coach or be to a new gym and they've
got their preconception about how you
should be moving and and sometimes that
can be overlaid erroneously I suppose
well I get it you know the whole eye
test we all want our movement to look
aesthetically pleasing you know we want
we want that over
squat to be instagram-worthy I get it
well yes is it so you know if we look at
like the very common box that people are
put in in regards to the squat in
particular it's that toe is completely
straightforward relatively narrow stance
and it's funny because that stance is
not optimal for most people like most
people can't squat to the depth of they
desire with their feet completely
straight
why's that they're in their feet just
shoulder-width apart it doesn't really
respect the common structure of the hip
the the orientation of the femoral neck
is such that 15 to 20 degrees of
external rotation at the start so like
just toes pointed out a little bit yep
ends to clear some space in the hip
joint at the bottom because keep in mind
the squat is an extreme range of motion
we're talking about all the way down
yeah we're talking about maxing out the
joint and so you at that point you have
to respect where the joint is most
congruent now if we're talking the
quarter squats or like jumping position
or like athletic position like like a
linebacker and the NFL or yeah yeah
that's a different conversation because
you're not squatting all the way down so
in that respect
a little bit more narrow stance toes
straight forward so that you can change
direction so you can drive straight into
the floor that's probably that's much
more understandable and valid you know
as an argument but you gave a really
good example of the wall ball and we use
the goblet squat as a way for people to
kind of figure out their natural squat
and groove so I just have them
experiment I say you know hold this 10
kilo kettlebell in front and just
experiment with different positions your
your general guidelines are your feet
you have to stay flat your knees have to
track kind of like middle of the foot
just naturally over the over the center
of the foot and then that's pretty much
it I I look at spinal position just kind
of if we have to clean it up we will I
like the goblet squat almost keeps
people upright just naturally yeah and
it's a really good tool for people to
explore and and that's what we have them
do and then we you know when they find a
comfortable position and they kind of
meet those criteria just you know steep
stay flat knees track over the middle of
foot we'll say okay try to bank that and
then let's see if we can recreate that
position under the bar okay it's a
process that way I understand so someone
that may be relatively new to the sport
of either weightlifting powerlifting
CrossFit anything that is requiring a
more I want to say a more extreme level
of mobility for one of a better term the
umbrella term for the things that we are
discussing at the moment someone who has
come into that it's likely that they're
going to have some deficiencies within
certain ranges or planes of movement is
that likely to be compensated by some in
other areas or there's some people who
come in and have got really poor
mobility globally I suppose you've got
people who are hyper flexible and there
must be people at the opposite end of
the scale as well of course yeah
everything's a bell curve everything's a
spectrum but I will I would argue again
that the people that walk into this into
the door that say ah I just don't have
the mobility it's because they haven't
provided their body with the appropriate
variation of the movement to set them up
for success it's very common for the
person that believes they don't have the
mobility to perform a snatch is because
all they try to do is max out their
snatch and their technique is so horrid
and they have none and they don't know
how to control their bodies that they're
bought that their body literally kind of
puts the ebrake on yeah yeah it's very
common that would say okay lay on the
table their mood their joints move just
fine or you know oh this ten pound ten
kilo kettlebell inferni I do a goblet
squat Oh looks like what lovely yeah
yeah it's beautiful to me what are you
talking about you know you're you are
correct though I'm not there are
certainly individuals who whose joints
do not go into the positions and then
some that go beyond the positions as
well right some people that are too
flexible some that some people have a
surplus of range of motion and those are
the people that you know it's really
just okay well you don't need to do
anything else but but train the
movements but train you know find the
amount of intensity that you can control
your position and can come back to the
gym day in and day out and you'll
probably get better yeah but you don't
need to stretch that's you know there's
that thing for those individuals but
even the individuals whose joints don't
go there it's still about finding the
appropriate variation in order to load
the joint at the range of motion that it
currently possesses and then over time
the body will adapt and range of motion
will be increased to the potential of
that particular structure like some
people are just not meant to be Gumby
you know it's the ideal but I think I
fall into that category yeah me too
you know it's okay I've got when I when
I get to courage here sometimes sometime
I'll release some footage some old
footage of me doing the lifts and then
I'll release the footage of me doing
them now and I'll say hey not us not a
stretch to be had and they're totally
opposite but it kind of gets me now to
the mechanism of of stretching and the
types I was gonna say you've touched
you've touched on one of the buzzwords
one of the few buzz words that we're
going to go through today you are you
would were directed towards stretch city
so someone has entered the gym they have
the desire to complete a particular
movement whatever that may be but they
are unable to get into the into the
position perhaps under load as you say
or perhaps under fatigue typically I
think I've tried to look broad
categories of what I think would be
proscribed
quotation marks and I think a
combination of soft tissue work static
stretching and dynamic stretching seemed
to be the kind of gold
- these are the things these are the
camps that you could do something in I
think there's a certainly what I see in
my experience is a lot of a lot of
weight towards static stretching mmm but
of those three would you say there's
anything else that is commonly
prescribed if it's bro - bro in the gym
or is there have we covered those the
three the soft tissue work the static in
the dynamic stretching yeah that covers
yet the other aspect evidence just do
more of the movement which that's what
that's what you'd prescribe right that's
the that's the dusted that's the actual
solution so you know spoiler alert
no you've just given away the end of the
movie month so let's start let's start
with soft tissue work can you tell us
what soft tissue work is and what people
think it does and what it actually does
I don't mean to be honest I don't know
the answers to any of those questions
but I can sure as hell try what it is i
we are talking generally about foam
rolling stick and a lacrosse ball and
various areas
whatever the fancy the gun thing that
caustics and the dollar therapy just on
the side just on the side point one of
the guys in our gym has come up with his
home solution to this which is a bandsaw
that he's removed the saw from Milland
milled a solid steel part welded it in
and it's 60 pounds so probably about 100
dollars and does the exact the exact
same thing but has about four times the
amount of torque there you go so sorry
sorry ther we go and I'm definitely not
gonna get one sent out to me now am i
you can whatever foam roller you like
the one that vibrates the one that's got
like the ball with the you know the
Wi-Fi connectivity has play Z music
keeps waterproof yeah let's just throw
all of those things in the same bucket
for now okay so knows the mecca we have
to talk about the mechanisms what they
do what they don't do we're going back
to the scientific f
here and it there's no evidence
currently there's no evidence to support
the common narratives of those things
break up your tissue as if we were made
of clay and I want so I'll just kind of
like let that soak in for a second
there's no evidence to say that you are
breaking up your scar tissue or
releasing or breaking up adhesions in
your tissues using these implements so
just just to interject that there's
micro tears which will occur in the
muscles during training is that correct
yes and the commonly held assumption is
that by rolling them on one of these
implements it will somehow smooth them
out help to break them up is that yeah
erroneous assumption it's just that it's
an assumption there's zero evidence to
support that absolutely not which is
shared there's some jaws on the floor at
the moment some none but let's let's
think about common sense here for a
second if you were able to rearrange
your tissues that way what what a
barbell sitting on your back due to you
in full straight through you would
disintegrate no you would have a
permanent dent in your upper trap your
barbell squat workout like you know
quite useful for lobha if you squat your
low bar that would be really useful like
a little shelf nice little groove there
it's that's a good point
what about sitting down your ass would
turn into Sponge Bob
you know but it shapes positive to the
seat yeah exactly and then also so
that's just the common sense rule in
that respect but also how can we
possibly select the tissues that we want
to break up the adhesions but yet it
leaves all the other tissues intact you
know how does that foam roller
selectively get down four layers deep to
the muscle but yet doesn't jack up the
fashion of the skin and how does it
perfectly realign the tissues the way
there's one really think about this it
sounds so stupid when you say it it's
not plausible it's just not possible
so what the
does say about these things is that they
you can have short-term range of motion
changes and you can have short-term
changes in perception in regards to what
you feel okay
so yeah and there are no argument there
my my argument is that you can get those
same changes with moving and there are
as evidence to show that that they
compare like just riding a bike
stationary bike for five minutes versus
foam rolling for five minutes you get
the same range of motion changes within
the the legs
yeah whatever they're testing it's like
usually at camp during whatever okay so
my point is why not do more of the
movement and no and then you will get
the same warm-up effect you will hit
that inflection point where you're like
oh you know things feel good now yeah
number two you will get more practice
with said movement so it comes down to
the skill acquisition thing it's just
it's just how do you plan on spending
your time I fit my general
recommendation with that stuff is if
you're going to do it minimum effective
dose meaning that if 20 seconds is
enough to foam roll your glutes or hip
flexor or whatever and your that makes
your squat feel better then there's no
need to do two minutes of it yeah
because there's diminishing returns
you're not breaking anything up so I
would recommend sticking those short
bouts in between the movement as a kind
of like a back-and-forth type of thing
okay so go in a little bit of a roll
yeah begin your squat barbell on your
back
couple of couple of repetitions then
back across roll something else exactly
maybe three or four rounds of that with
your warmup sets of back squat and then
you're good to like you're good okay can
you explain about the the pain
perception thing because I know that
that does actually have a you've
mentioned it has a contributing a
positive contributing factor yeah so
what they test is something called pain
pressure threshold where essentially
they poked a person they have their like
with like you know it's like think about
just poking somebody with your finger
they use it like a pressurized tool to
gauge the amount of pressure that it
takes yeah
for the person to perceive at these
types I think the person rates the
discomfort level and then they foam roll
and then they poke them again and
there's a decrease in pain perception
I'm gonna make two arguments here okay
you can't possib oh is inherent in
everything that we do the words that I
say the exercises that we give placebo
is inherent and everything we can't
blind the participants to the foam
rolling
so there's don't don't think about
what's happening ignore the failing any
leg there's nothing going on here right
so there may be a testing effect there
yep but no number two let's say there's
not a testing effect and that's a true
change in perceptual physiology it's
synonymous with if you bang your knee
against the table and you'd like rub it
really fast you know how you like you'd
hit your knee like [ __ ] and you and you
rub it down you're just you're just
basically taking a sensory stimulus and
overriding another sensory input okay
or if you Jam your finger and then you
shake it in the air really fast that's
your natural way of creating a sensory
overload to try to override the pain
perception does that make sense yeah
absolutely so where if if there's such
tenuous research that is showing any
efficacy for soft tissue work who were
where it was where's the Charlatans that
have been propagating this where did
they come from
you got to ask that man good a try I got
a track back up to the the guy in the
sky in the sky just think about just
think about it from a marketing
standpoint I mean it's sexy and it sells
and it's easier than training really
hard it sounds like it works sure it
sounds fancy and it's vitamins and
slippery sliding surfaces and muscle
fibers and right I can PR my my snatch
without actually having to work really
hard for the next two years and put my
head down and come to the gym so I you
know it sounds I know I sound like a
crow Majin and I would have but it's
important for people to understand not
necessarily what they do because we
don't really other than what I just
mentioned we don't really know but
more important to learn what they
currently don't do yeah and so that way
you can if you're going to implement
them you implement them in the most
efficient way possible which again is my
thing is like short effective bouts in
between your movements okay so someone's
someone's working on let's say the squat
because we talked about it a lot today
you would recommend getting warm to the
point at which they are warm enough and
then you've said what 20 seconds to 20
seconds to a minute of rolling within an
area and then go and move yeah exactly
now I don't just to be clear I don't
actually recommend any of that stuff yep
yep I recognize if someone's unable to
let go of the tether to the beloved foam
roller exactly that would be most
effective way to do it right exactly so
you know what if you want to do that
stuff I get that it feels good I totally
get that yep so this is the way that I
wouldn't exactly like that short bouts
if it's let's say you're going you're
gonna do a squad and then you're gonna
do an overhead press so you'll you'd
foam roll your glutes and hip flexors or
whatever in between sets of your warm up
in between your warm-up sets of squats
and then you would actually train your
squat and you'd not worry about the foam
roller you'd have your training mind on
and then it's like okay I have to
overhead press I'm gonna warm up with
the empty bar overhead pressing and then
I'm gonna go foam roll my lats for 20
seconds there you know I'm just making
up time period it could be 10 seconds it
could be 30 so I think anything beyond
that is probably just a waste of time
and then you're back and forth with
going a little heavier in the press and
maybe three or four rounds of that and
then well you're when you're up to
you're like last couple either second to
last or last warm-up set certainly your
working sets of your particular lifts
just don't worry about that stuff
put the [ __ ] foam roller down you've
got some weight to lift please yes so
can you just quickly okay can you just
quickly explain how a massage fits into
this sure it fits in a very similar way
and I know that you know you've probably
lost whoever is a soft tissue therapists
right now listening to your show is
immediately fine or dolphin so there's
it's the same conversation there's no
evidence
currently just say that somebody's hands
can magically rearrange somebody's
tissue selectively again it's just not
plausible now we may be looking at the
wrong thing so any topic I have the I
reserve the right to change my mind when
evidence is presented to me however
there is no evidence suggesting that it
does have any efficacy at the moment on
on from a biomechanic from a bio
mechanics standpoint no okay
so what was the very briefly can you
explain the study I think it was done on
mice or rats where this came from about
soft tissue work mmm yeah sure there's I
mean the narrative on soft tissue work
is being that's been a lot longer than
those those studies but they've done
stuck bats with the instrument assisted
soft tissue work the metal tools and the
study that is most cited what they did
was they rupture the little mice MCLs
and then it was like a six-week protocol
of scraping the right mice MCO with
tools versus none nothing at all and at
the end of the six weeks they did show
that the group that got the scraping
their MCL tissues were more aligned to
normal whereas the control group it
still showed abnormal fiber alignment
you know where the tear was yeah or
parallel at all there's no scar tissue
had built up all these things so it's
like okay that's you know that's some
evidence of plausibility in mice the kid
the kicker is not that mice physiology
is so much different than ours but it's
the logistics of it the mice were put to
sleep when the scraping took place and
then they were using human size tools so
they were using it to of bigger than the
bigger than the animal so the amount of
force that was applied to the tissues
was beyond the what we could what we
could tolerate as humans it's be they've
been unable to recreate those effects in
human studies it's be it's beyond
physiological realm there there's an
actual there's a 3d model in 2008
chaudhary
is the lead author and they tried to
make a model to how much how much
pressure would it take to realign these
types of fibers to create shear in the
fibers and it was sometimes it was up
were in humans it was upwards of 2,000
pounds of force to create a 1% change
something like that but it was and then
like the caveat was well you could
create a 4% change in the bridge of the
the fashion of the bridge of the nose so
like pinch the skin on the top of your
nose so and it was like almost beyond
physiological realm to create that
amount of change so it's just it was
implausible that's for everyone who
everyone who needs soft tissue work
doing in the nose right exactly so and
then the other areas was like the
fashion lotta and the planner fascist so
like the IT band and the bottom of the
foot so very thick fibrous bands and it
was just beyond what we could tolerate
you know your flesh your skin and flesh
would rip apart with that amount of
force before you ever got to the muscle
adhesions and when you laid on a 30
centimeter piece of foam rolling up and
down on a softer floor is definitely not
applying that much force no and and so
that was sheer force there are some
organs to be made well what about
compression what about what about
compression plus shear and I get it we
haven't necessarily studied every
different tannoy pasted right exactly
and so there may be a way to create
plastic change if the force is great
enough and if it's frequent or if it's
frequent enough but in real life you're
not getting you're not getting a very
extremely aggressive massage five times
a day there's only the type of
prescription that it would take and I
bet you that the changes would be
minimal over time anyway but you would
get four or change with just consistent
movement under load and you would get
the motor skill acquisition part of
training if you did it that way so now
to your question of where does massage
fit into this and and you know SMR with
foam rollers it's not to say that that
stuff has has zero place I don't
implement or recommend currently but I
can see the applicability not for
directly in the movement itself or even
pre-workout but
the notion of winding down and the
notion of recovering and and quieting
the mind and and these types of things
that I do think there's probably some
effect there's some decent effect on
meditation you know shifting the body
into some type of parasympathetic state
however that's defined so I recommend
longer bouts of form rolling like again
if the person just like sit there like
I'm gonna do it just tell me the best
way to do it like alright it's a
relaxing meditative pursuit right I
think post workout and on training on
the off days I think post workout the
effect is not the actual area that
you're rolling but it's the routine it's
the winding down routine like I'm foam
rolling now it's the workouts over I can
start to chill out and yeah well they'll
almost certainly be a reduction in
cortisol and if you're if you're going
to be anxious or frantic about the fact
that you haven't done the thing today
that you thought you were going to do on
your day off right
yeah totally now if you're if you're
that stuck on your routine like maybe
that's another problem but I you know my
point I think we may have I think we may
have opened up some people's routines
and freed them up from a couple of a
couple of half-hour bouts here in there
today so far my post workout routine is
just chilling you know I take off my
shoes and I sit you know or maybe I'll
lay on my back and just chill but some
people might want to just kind of roll
out like it feels good but and that's
fine that it whatever it gets you to
wind down you get your appetite back get
you to just kind of like recover for the
next bout I think massage has a similar
thing yeah the lights are dim you're
relaxed you're just chilling somebody
else is doing something for you like
you're treating yourself yes just
something nice and that has just a
general effect but understand what's
happening here
yeah and understand what's not happening
it's probably more important yeah okay
so moving on static stretching what do
people think it does and what does it do
it's almost an identical conversation
they're the evidence there's more
evidence on static stretching just
because they've been studying it longer
okay and the evidence kind of keeps
saying the same thing is that we're not
really creating
permanent changes in the muscle tendon
structure like the pan-asian angle the
where the the tendon and muscle meat
like that juncture point doesn't really
change permanently it's like not when
you when you stretch and there's an
increased change in range of motion it
doesn't stick that way it goes back okay
so it's a way that they describe the
effects of static stretching the reason
why changes your short your range of
motion short term which it does by the
way just like foam rolling can is that
it increases your tolerance to stretch
so so think it's a nervous system thing
okay think about this
if somebody lays on the table and they
try to put their arm over their head and
it doesn't quite go all the way over
their head if they were put under
anesthesia it's very likely that that
arm would just flap to the table okay
yeah unless they've got some type of
like doorstop in their shoulder joint
you know an accent phony arias physical
imbalance some people do and in that
case we're just not throwing a barbell
over their head or you know we're doing
landmine presses or something like that
but anyway if that if that same person
who is under anesthesia slot their arm
flops over their head and then they wake
up you know a couple hours later and
then all of a sudden they're kind of
that restriction is back I don't that's
that tone whatever we want to call that
that nervous system holding pattern is
what stretching works in - yeah so I'm
right in saying his tone is tightness is
tone is similar to tightness that's a
word that I've been trying to define for
like three years now I'm not even gonna
say it I haven't opened up opened up
Pandora's box of groceries I don't know
how to define tone I don't know what's
because if somebody's relaxed completely
tone would would hypothetically be zero
yeah but there's still some type of
something's holding there so I don't
know what it is but I do know that
warming up literally getting warm and
moving through range of motion well will
give you that same change in range of
motion as that expression and they've
also shown that PNF stretching contract
relax adding some load to the stretch
actively
yeah is a there alternative as well it
gives you range of motion changes faster
and headed ahead of static stretching
correct me like my favorite hamstring
stretches in RDL like a hold of light
kettlebell Romanian deadlift total light
kettlebell hold it between your legs and
just kind of sink into that hip hip
hinge position yeah take a couple let's
sink a little bit further so it's like a
light bill you know something that you
can hold and sustain you're letting that
eight do its thing you're letting
gravity do its thing all the while your
hamstrings are still being contracted
essentially yeah but you know but
they're also being stretched so that's
kind of a an example of what people have
like described what we talked about it's
like loaded mobility get into the
positions and hang out there yeah you
know it's it's active your body don't
you'll melt and put into position and
you'll have the same effects with the
skill of the position okay I understand
so can you explain how someone like a
gymnast or a yoga instructor that I'm
sure everyone's got a friend who well
she's done yoga for five years and she
can get into the over splits now or she
can do a backbend yep where if static
stretching doesn't elicit a long-term
effect how is it that these people have
been able to get into these what appear
to be extreme positions I was gonna I
was gonna go there and I forgot I'm glad
you brought backup there's always a
spectrum to things so let's say somebody
is a gymnast and that person has been
training for 15 years and since the age
of like six there's a combination it's
it's likely I don't know what to what
extent but because of the frequency of
training what did I say with soft tissue
if the load is heavy enough if the
frequency is high enough because of the
frequency over years yeah there is
likely some type of structural
adaptation but think about the training
for a second it's it's with gymnastics
specifically it's very active gymnasts
can do the splits in the air big they
can do it actively
they can hold these isometric positions
so they've been loading these possess
strength through range as well right so
my argument is because based on current
literature it's limited because we don't
have a we're not tracking like a gymnast
over the course of years I think that if
we did that you would likely you would
probably see some type of change in the
architecture of the muscle but I'm gonna
argue that that change is relatively
small compared to the positions that
they can tolerate and I'm gonna go back
to the fact that they have trained the
ability to tolerate the positions yeah
now they are closer to the person who's
under anesthesia because the person
who's under anesthesia has not trained
for years to be able to tolerate the
stretch yeah so with the gymnast if you
want to think about their nervous system
how is them to go there because they've
trained it so often and we you know over
the course of many many years that the
nervous system is saying okay this must
be okay
we're not threatened in this position
hmm yeah because even if as you say some
of these approaches have a very marginal
marginal or negligible gain when you
multiply that five times a week over 15
years exact large '''l gain actually
becomes quite pronounced exactly right
and and then okay somebody who wants to
do a snatch is like oh they're not you
know I need to do that like no you don't
need that extreme yeah you know they
look at the dream situations and I think
that's what they need you don't have to
be a gymnast to do an overhead squat I
promise you in fact the muscles are not
even that stretch your knee the
hamstrings not stretch because your knee
is bent yep you know you're hit your hip
flexor is slacked because your hip is in
flexion yep your quads you're a
read-only quad that crosses two muscles
is your rectus femoris and that's bent
at the at the hip
so that's slacked there's really no
muscle that is extremely stretched from
a lower body position from from an upper
body position at your lat to some extent
in your pecs but that wide grip and the
snatch usually not a limiting factor and
if you can do a push you know behind the
neck push press with this that with a
snatch grip or
power snatch then you you have the
shoulders it's about integrating it so I
think people have this misunderstanding
that you need to be you have to have
flexibility of a gymnast yeah nor it's
into the position you simply don't now
with a yogi that's another example
that's interesting I think that there's
some selection bias there I you want you
are not gonna I'm not wired to be bendy
like that like stretching yeah obviously
I have a bias here I've hated stretching
since kindergarten because it's for me I
don't I have that unlike wired to be to
resist that crap like my body doesn't
like it and I gotta get weird like
nervous system tension type things when
I'm trying to do as a doctor of physical
therapy I'm sure is probably well maybe
for a doctor but there's certainly gonna
be a lot of physiotherapists who
wouldn't who probably wouldn't put
themselves in that camp am aware of a
lot of them that would that would love
the mobility that would love spending
time doing the static stretching in the
soft tissue work and it would appear
that you're you know you're not happy
stretching at all I mean I'd rather I
like to Train qualities that are that
have some type of functionality and yeah
I don't really care about stretching
yeah okay
I want the range of motion for the tasks
so not for its own sake not for its own
sense that's correct so I think that
people are drawn to certain tasks that
they're better at naturally so I think
that a lot of yoga instructors drop
their bodies probably lend themselves
for whatever reason to relatively bendy
well you're not getting in you know
you're not going to pursue a career as a
the owner of a yoga studio and yoga
teacher if you look [ __ ] doing yoga
that's all I'm saying or if it's a
bullock or yoga classes today where I it
[ __ ] sweat and sweat and shake and
swear at myself and I'm ponding at the
front of the class exactly and I think
that also think of a gymnast like do you
really think the people who suck at
gymnastics and whose bodies are
continually playing tug-of-war with
themselves are gonna stick with
gymnastics for 15 years
probably not probably not they're gonna
go find something that lends they're you
know lends itself better with their
attributes so I think that there is some
selection bias that people are not
accounting for okay so that is
consistent with the literature showing
that you know there's limitation with
these passing modalities okay
dynamic stretching up next sure can you
define can you like give me an example
to something edging is like you could
just do the movement could be considered
dynamic stretching that was something I
was going to say exactly get you've
spoiled we've spoiled the each of this
films sorry this all others are out
there tight Avengers all over again on
Facebook so dynamic stretching for me
would be something like a pendulum swing
with your foot so swinging your foot
forwards and back standing on one leg
and that allowing your foot to swing
forward and back stretching your
hamstring and then I guess your hip
flexor and quad at the back that would
technically be I think what I would
consider dynamic stretching is that
anything is that just swinging my leg
around
it is definitely swinging your leg
around a little grumpy because I'm doing
sets of 10 in the back squat and I just
got done maybe half an hour after we
college that just to kind of give the
listeners some talk about the salute lee
find codings waiting for this waiting
through the [ __ ] is the exact reason
that i wanted to have you on I have
taken a I have evolved quite a bit over
the past I'd say eight years on these
topics and I dynamic stretching I guess
is the lesser of two evils if you're
gonna choose one of the other I'm gonna
just lay on my back and try to tug on my
hamstrings or I'm gonna do a standing
leg swing like you described I would
take the standing leg swing why because
it is act because there there is
evidence to show that dynamic stretching
can give you the short term ranges of
motion changes that and without the
power decrease of static stretching oh
that's something we didn't even touch on
can ya can you briefly explain about
that sure so there's there was a few
studies showing that bouts of static
stretching like 30 to 60 second bouts
and decrease in the short-term for a
short period of time can decrease your
top end power output so the way that
they set up these studies were like they
did a hamstring stretch like a hip
flexor stretch or a calf stretch and
then they had the people immediately go
on to a force plate and do a vertical
jump okay and static stretching effect
of that but since they have come out
with literature showing that if you do
static stretching and then followed up
with some type of dynamic stretch or
movement like they were doing like a
skips you know like walking lunges these
types of thoughts like that then
mitigates the power loss from static
stretching okay which which is more real
life like most people don't do a static
stretch and then just go right to a max
of something yeah they don't they don't
do like a single leg quad stretch and
then immediately go do a single leg leg
extension yeah exactly so in that
respect I think that it's pretty benign
like the power loss yeah but it was that
was was there a time window of when that
starts to tail off it's like an hour oh
wow so it's actually quite quite
significant if you're doing it within
your within the same training session
it's like it's definitely effective but
at the same time well you know what is
one two three percent is what they found
which there's probably some measurement
error there is where like one to three
percent decreases in power but also that
matters for like a few amount of people
and it also matters if you plan on doing
max effort training so if I know that my
training today is only gonna be like 70
to 80 percent for reps yeah it's
probably not a big deal
and I know also know that if I'm gonna
I'll do some if I'm gonna do some static
stretching I'm probably gonna go and do
the empty bar for a bunch and I'm gonna
do a bunch of warm-up sets that probably
doubles as my dynamic warmup I was going
to say yeah it's about potentiation so I
think what happens is it almost relaxes
the body mm-hmm so like I think that
static stretching it's the same as kind
of foam rolling it almost tells your
body oh it's kind of chill and so like
that is not synonymous with doing
something max effort very explosively
yeah so you got to potentiate that
effect so if you're gonna static stretch
start to work back into like doing
dynamic stuff which you know leg swings
could it be one of those things because
you're
your body is it's that's that's a fast
stretch contract stretch contracts
stretch contract I think that
potentiates the nervous system to
prepare itself for movement better than
static stretching okay so I think we've
moved through what I would consider the
three main areas that most people would
use towards this zenith term of mobility
have you got a more optimal approach
that people can use you've alluded to it
a couple of times about doing the
movement yeah is it is it just
progressive overload its progressive
overload just king of everything I mean
ultimately yes but if we're overloading
reload assumes that you're like we're
talking about weight on the bar but
really if we're talking about skill
acquisition weight on the bar will
naturally come what time so it's more
getting into the position is kind of a
different conversation but you have to
practice so you mentioned three things
and I people I think people spend way
too much time doing and not enough time
doing the actual movement like they
freaked out because they're not happy
with the position that they're hitting
for like two reps and then like I've got
to go do this nonspecific thing for half
an hour now to the training movement you
have to reorient yourself it's just so
much wasted time so those three things
soft-tissue passive dynamic I think a
priority dynamic is probably better but
it's all kind of the same recommendation
in that do it kind of in between the
actual movement so that you do you have
time efficiency and you also you get
that short-term change in a range of
motion but you get to use it right away
yeah I think I think you we definitely
haven't concluded here that soft tissue
static or dynamic stretching don't
elicit a short-term improvement in
someone's range of motion
it's the pathway that that works on
which which has been erroneously
classified is that is that correct to
say exactly right and so then that
dictates how you implement it so if you
if if you do ten minutes let's say you
do 15 minutes I think it's probably
pretty standard for people like 15
minutes of foam rolling maybe if another
ten of static stretching like yeah it's
not unreasonable to think that people
spend twenty five
thirty minutes doing these things you
you've probably lost some of the
short-term benefit from the first five
minutes you'd have to be real radio
theater end yeah think about it if you
do a total body thing and you hit your
your you know calves first and then you
hit your shoulders last you're probably
hitting need to do your calves again let
me like the full bridge you just come to
me yeah so it's much better to pick one
spot and then go use it right away go
load it right away and the load will
further allow you to get into a new
range of motion it will further
desensitize some of the feelings of
restriction and no apprehension to the
movement so that's I think the best way
to implement it and also just you've got
us trust the process if you want real
changes in your structure and your
movement you've got to put your head
down and commit to coming to the gym for
months on end yeah you know I always say
like talk to me in six months and let's
see if there's a change like don't worry
about tomorrow and also think about like
don't panic when the movement doesn't
feel its best because that's pretty much
life like it example is like you and I'm
sure that you can attest this I can you
walk into the gym it's like all right I
got squats there I got snatches you do
that first air squat and you're like oh
god life is today gravity feels so heavy
yeah and then what happens is people are
like oh man I got to go warm up and so
they do that twenty or thirty minutes of
the nonspecific thing but what if what
if you were like alright that's what for
like [ __ ] I'm gonna take that twenty or
thirty minutes that I was gonna do this
nonspecific thing yeah and I'm gonna
subdued twenty or thirty more minutes of
like squatting I was gonna say we could
we could try and do an experiment with
the listeners right now and the next
time that someone goes into the gym and
a particular movement let's say that
it's squat because this would be
applicable to a front squat a back squat
or an overhead squat instead of them
going away or instead of them beginning
a session before going and doing this
movement with foam rolling and the
static stretching the dynamic stretching
what would you have them do instead work
up from a PVC bar get themselves warm
and then start to put a little bit of
weight on the bar and move around for
that half an hour instead focusing on
movement quality yeah I don't think it
has to be a half an hour I think that's
overkill yeah definitely be knocked it
by the end of that yeah now that the
it's hard the exact way that I would
tweak the movement for their specific
parameters because there are ways you
can elevate your heels a little bit you
can use a little bit of weight like just
enough weight so you can feel the
movement to get you down there but it's
hard to say on that general thing
because everybody's a little different
but what I would recommend is that you
slow the tempo down you find a little
bit of load in which you can you can
pause at your end range what it
currently is your end range and that you
can go slow in both directions and
really feel the movement and I bet that
over the course of 5 10 15 minutes your
body for lack of a better term starts to
melt into position just like it would if
you were static stretching but in this
case you're practicing the movement and
you would hit that inflection point of
feeling warm you know that feeling where
you're like something inside of you just
clicks and you're like okay I'm ready
it's like um it's kind of like body
lucidity right there everything's moving
the the central nervous systems firing
we haven't mentioned CNS yet or to too
much yet but it's all CNS yeah and I
don't know what that inflection point is
I don't know what we could call it but
it's that moment where you're like
alright I'm ready to I got grease in the
groove like mentally I'm there my body
feels good let's have some weight like
I'm what it's weird isn't it it's going
this room it's going from getting out of
the car and [ __ ] I need to let the dog
out later on too I'm here to Train and
there is you're right because it's at
what point do you go from being that guy
to the guy that's ready to PR is Scott
clean or whatever it might be and I
would argue that the fastest point from
the time that you walk in to the time
that you get to that point is a straight
line and that straight line is doing the
movement doing more of the movement
doing the movement doing more of the
movement yep with pauses with tempos now
again again over the course of that
experiment you may you might find that
you know what this gives me 80% all the
passive stuff has only given me
about 20% this gives me 80% but I still
want that extra little boost that's
where you can layer on that other stuff
in between yeah but I would recommend if
you can cut as much of that out as you
can in the beginning and focus on more
of the movement with light loads and you
know incrementally smaller jumps and
you're used to and see if your body
doesn't hit that sweet spot anyway
because because aren't you correct me if
I'm wrong but aren't you gonna have to
reorient yourself to the movement
regardless like let's say you walk over
to the barbell you do your first
overhead squat you're like that feels
like garbage yep then you go through all
your passive stuff are you not gonna
have to go back and do the bar warm-up
anyway a familiarize yourself if you
grid to every position before you know
you've been at the gym for an hour and
you haven't done anything there
definitely definitely to me that feels
like it's just such an arduous long task
warming ups yes it does suck it sucks an
awful lot yeah it's it and you write as
well that this time that you could be
spending grease in the groove and
drilling the movement that your is the
end goal right yes it's practicing
pushing your foot on the pedal instead
of actually just driving the car exactly
like I'm not pushing you foot on the
pedal you're pushing your foot on a
pretend pedal that's outside now you
know what if the splits are a part of
your sport if you're a gymnast dancer
competitive cheerleader these types of
things then you're damn right you're
gonna be doing the splits and you're
gonna be doing them a lot but you're
gonna also be holding them isometrically
you know you're gonna be doing things
that require control in that range of
motion it's all about specificity you
mentioned it's progressive overload King
I would say that specificity is king if
overload happens to be the thing that
you want because your specific quality
of choice is strength or power then yes
we have to progressively overload over
time but specificity is king so the
splits is not gonna get you that
overhead squat that you want the
overhead squat is gonna give you the
overhead squat that you want you just
have to be patient enough with the
tediousness of what it takes just to
practice over and over and over and over
and it is tedious and it's not fun yeah
but nothing what is it is nothing worth
having comes easy right exactly and this
is a reason this is the reason why I
think a lot of the time certainly for
myself when I started doing Olympic
weightlifting and CrossFit and looking
at these more complicated movements we
forget just how extreme they are the
fact that being able to do a bar
muscle-up because we see the best
athletes in the world able to do sets of
10 or 20 and we see people be able to
squat clean 300 300 pounds and you know
I mean the people who were able to move
these large amounts of weight and do
them oh wow he's done it under fatigue
you did it after a run by crew and he
did it you know on on stage in front of
the entire why PMF or whatever it might
be
yeah you forget just how much of an
achievement it is to be able to do them
full stop and I think that it can down
regulate people's people's understanding
that it is a challenge in itself and
they can very quickly begin to look past
that and and and believe that they
should be moving more or should be
moving faster than they are and I think
that definitely leads to a short-term
astir strategy as opposed to what you
were saying come back to me in six
months do this considerably and come
back to me and stick to six months
you're 100% correct people see the end
product they don't see that that purse
all those people that you described have
been busting their ass in the gym
training for probably years yeah 10,000
failed reps to get that one totally
sacrificing other things in their life
to get there so it's one of the channel
Wesley Smith of juggernaut kind of he
describes that in regards to program and
like people will look at Ray Williams
program or look at Chad's program or
like the best of the best and say oh
well I just need to be on their program
but they there's a there's a process to
this thing you know those guys their
program now looked nothing like their
program when they were an intermediate
lifter and then that looked nothing like
their program when they were a beginner
yeah so you've got a this thing you know
it works in stages you can't just jump
to the end you can have yeah I have the
end in mind
but let's like you said you got a you
know
the process a little bit and it takes
time so it was very freeing for me
because I've been on that side of the
spectrum when I was warming up when I
first started physical therapy school at
the beginning of my weightlifting career
just like nine ten years ago I was
hooking a band up to every joint in my
body I was this is suspended from the
rig thousand percent collected like a
sex swing in the middle of a
weightlifting Club no I wouldn't even go
into the gym yet because I had too much
up too much gear to throw around like I
had to go into the like the indoor track
because I had to spread out all my bands
and all my foam rollers I know in the
ball lacrosse I could not like an
obstacle course of mobility tools and I
you know it was an hour
I either lee an hour of spending time
doing that and then I would then I would
have to spend thirty minutes trying to
get into the positions because that
stuff just didn't really have that big
of an effect but when I started to
forget that and start to pay more
attention to the positions and stay
lighter for longer like not like an
empty bar cuz sometimes you need a
little bit of weight to feel the
positions yeah but I wouldn't I started
to not to increase load I started to
think about it in a different way sort
of ask myself different questions is it
too heavy for me to lift or is it too
heavy for me to lift the way I want to
yeah and some those thresholds are a
little different so I would stay in the
ladder for longer and my bodies blow and
behold started to become more
comfortable and consistent with those
positions and so I started to take the
approach of raising my minimums instead
of trying to worry about my top and all
the time and I moved yeah I think that's
so that's so correct my main movement
and mobility however you want to call
those things all that stuff improve when
I started just thinking about training
as a process and it was very liberating
when I stopped it took some time and it
wasn't cold turkey I'll tell you that
right now
yeah it slowly started to cut that stuff
out like oh that's this drill or this
like fan distraction drill isn't quite
working for me I'll just I'll chop this
one I'll keep everything else but I'll
chop this one an over course of it
probably took I mean honestly it
probably took a couple years yeah -
really we are I am now
but it was very very liberating it's
very liberating to just come into the
gym like I'll do something like I call
them knee bends I'd do like a bunch of
quarter squats in my bare feet yep just
like dip and drive dip and drive dip and
drive to like warm up my ankles to warm
up my knees to just kind of get some
blood flow for lack of a better term or
whatever yep I put my shoes on and I'm i
play with the empty barbell until I hit
that first inflection point yeah and
then I play with 40 kilos until I hit
that first inflection point and then I
and I just build from there and it's
it's freeing man I tell ya but it is
well I mean how many times a couple of
things I know that you're on a tight
schedule so I'm gonna fit a couple of
bits in here how many times do people
say that they don't have it they don't
have enough time in training to work the
technique but the they are spending 20
minutes on the foam roller or doing the
static stretching or the dynamic
stretching or whatever and you know
hopefully here people will be able to
see am I right in saying I think I think
I know your answer to this would you see
there being no difference between the
sort of strength and conditioning side
of something and the mobility training
that it would be a paradigm or a scale
or a spectrum should I say of load
intensity and training intensity
absolutely so viewing it as viewing it
as two separate things is an erroneous
way to look at it and I think hopefully
I certainly know that I'm going to very
very gingerly try and I'm going to try
and dial back my mobility my traditional
mobility addiction and like you say
begin to down-regulate just how much of
that I believe I need but I do think
that one of the things that I really
liked about what you've what you've said
in in this conversation is that if you
feel like it works for you and if you
enjoy the process that that in itself is
a therapeutic and beneficial addition to
your training that if you enjoy yin yoga
because you find that it gives you a
sense of mindfulness and it's zeros you
win for the day
then crack on but understand the pathway
that this is working on hundred percent
I don't wanna I'm not trying to spit in
everybody's Cheerios and also if your
training is going really well and you're
doing all of these things also and you
like it and everything is going well
like don't change a thing yeah just
stick to the program we've just said
it's back to the [ __ ] program yeah
this conversation is for the people who
feel like they're at a dead end and
they've been doing things that have not
have simply not been working if it's
been months and it ain't working it
probably not going to I understand so
where can the listeners find you online
so yeah so the cool thing about having a
weird name is that you can just search
my name and my views that's maybe a
write-up so Instagram I think it's Quinn
dot henyk DPT similar on Twitter and
then on Facebook I have to just quit and
Nick is my personal and then I have a
business one that's Quinn henyk DPT but
I pretty much just post the same [ __ ] on
both I don't know why I have to and then
clinical athlete is our our baby that
we're trying to help to bridge the
knowledge gap for all this stuff
strength conditioning health care so
clinical athlete on all of the common
social media channels also clinical Ally
is a directory of accredited
physiotherapists that you vetted right
exactly it's a forum as well okay so
it's also community on top of that
absolutely and we do yeah continuing
education courses and and it's trying to
connect athletes with healthcare
providers who understand their goals you
know what's going on yeah exactly and a
lot of the things that we've talked
about you know I do we do exercises and
drills and different exercise movement
variations that helped with motor skill
acquisition a lot of those are on my
youtube channel and on I've done a
several videos on the juggernaut YouTube
channel people will check those out that
I absolutely loved loved all of the
series that that we've touched on hey
yeah they were really really good we've
done yeah and I've done a ton with those
they very grateful for them allowing me
to use that that platform and
and yeah and then I have a book I also
have a book it's called weightlifting
I'm looking at the title credits so
weight lifting movement assessment and
optimization
so such Quinn henyk weight lifting
optimization it'll come up on Amazon
right we had some Amazon exactly and
it's essentially breaking down the
snatch and the clean and jerk by phase
so each phase of the lift what are our
terms that we've used today what are the
mobility and stability demands of each
phase and then how you do how do you
develop those phases with uses of the
lifts they're variations of the lifts
and then different kind of positional
drills and exercises that can help you
better create comfort and proficiency
within those positions so it's pretty
much exactly what we've talked about
today but at length I couldn't I
couldn't thank you enough for this I
think hopefully we will have opened some
people's eyes I think that going by what
the science says is something that we're
prepared to take when it comes to
medicine a lot of people are very
skeptical of esoteric new wave solutions
holistic solutions because of the
disinformation and because of the lack
of clarity when it comes to stuff like
mobility and physical training people
are prepared to take whatever is in
front of them or whatever everyone else
does I think that going by what the
science says which is what you've
presented us with today is definitely
giving people all of the facts and then
I suppose what they choose to do with it
whether they're able to relinquish their
stretching routine from here is a
decision of theirs oh and that's a thing
too and I I'm no i don't i fall into the
same camp you know we've got a we've all
got to question our biases a little bit
and be open to changing our ideas if
evidence is presented to us you know or
don't but that is there and again that
goes for me too and so these are the
ideas and thoughts as as i'm
interpreting the current literature and
you know if we do another show in three
years maybe Mike's doing his chain
and maybe I'm more affirmed in these
idea maybe thought that maybe set the
dual wielding Farah guns and maybe I'm a
state agent you know I switched
completely in you you know you
interviewed me on why my life changed so
you know couldn't thank you so much for
your time I really appreciate it thank
you Chris
it was a blast cheers man all right
[Music]